hi everybody I'm Nancy O'Dell with ET on
TV Abby Lee Miller is here you know I'm
very excited I love this show Dancing
with the Stars two Dance Moms how much
fun did you have here tonight like a lot
of fun I didn't have to deal with one
mother are you kidding me it was
fabulous I know you have a ton of
experience judging competitions what are
you looking for tonight with our dancers
straight legs pointed feet perfect
musicality inspiration emotional changes
pretty much everything you were like one
of the toughest guest judges that I've
seen up here you kept it real I got to
say you you kept it real up here and
then and that what did you think of how
some of the reactions were to you of
course a lot of people are thinking Val
and Mac said that your presence wasn't
needed here on a classy show what would
you say to him it's like I think he
doesn't really know the real me and he
probably hasn't done his homework on my
credentials and my kids that are in
wicked and Newsies and if then and it
took her tizzy in here working and all
the tours and you know on the other TV
shows I've done a lot of work all right
so who do you take it for the win who's
getting the ball at the mirror ball at
the very end of the song I think it's
gonna come down to a me party or the
merrill party yes